hello everyone and welcome to an
incredibly wild game from round seven of
the melt water champions chester finals
it's magnus crossing versus uh temur
rajabov and uh well this game has it all
and most importantly as the title
suggests it's a game that was played
between stalkfish and alpha zero uh in
their famous match in 2017 in london
that uh you guys have seen uh so let's
uh let's see what this game is all about
magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with e4 we have e5 knight to f3 knights
to c6 and the bishop to b5 going for the
real opus and nowadays everyone just
goes for the berlin defense we have
knight to f6 and magnus says we're not
going to trade anything just d3 and
we're playing a game uh we have bishop
the c5 and now bishop captures on c6
much like he played against nakamura we
have d captures on c6 and now
magnus castles and now if you remember
we mentioned that you can defend this
pawn in a variety of ways you can go
knight to d7 queen to e7 you can bring
the bishop back to d6 like nakamura did
uh but here we have knight to d7 this is
the line that java chooses and now c3
making uh a room for this pawn to be
pushed to d4 to grab more space in the
center and a job of castles and now d4
magnus strikes in the center and now
bishop to d6 uh so nicely keeping an eye
on that e5 pawn we have bishop to g5 and
here you have to defend somehow your
queen is attacked then you could play f6
or you could bring the queen to e8 uh
wesley so
played f6 here many times in this
position with great success he won some
games he drew some games i don't think
he ever lost the game uh
the the the win uh in this position with
f6 was against taliresa ferruccia but uh
rajab goes queen to e8 and uh it's not a
bad move it's the move that uh alpha
zero played uh in uh the match against
stockfish we rooked to e1 and now in the
match against stockfish stockfish uh uh
also played rook to e1 uh and alpha zero
played f6 in this position but uh rajab
plays c5 so he improves on alpha zero's
move and it is now as of march 10 that
we have a completely new game so uh the
there's a lot of pressure on the center
but magnus has discovered so he
continues with uh the development of his
queen side knight can now come to c2
could also come to c4 attack the bishop
you could come to b5 all depending on
what black plays
so our job of capturing the center ones
we have c captures and only now f6
chasing away this bishop bishop to h4
and now knight to b6 controlling c4 here
and bishop to g3 now by magnus we have
bishop to g4 pinning the knight and
magnus just moves the queen
on pins and delivers check so queen to
b3 check king to h8 and now knight to b5
putting pressure on the bishop here uh
so here bishop captures an f3 first now
asking do you want to capture with the
queen so i grab the knight on b5 or do
you want to mess up your king's side so
magnus has to mess up the king side he
plays g captures on f3 and now rook to
d8
now you are ready to uh recapture if
needed even with the pawn then you will
have a nice pawn mass in the center so
rook ate the c1 magnus putting more
pressure on the c7 square and now queen
to e7 another java just defends it with
a for now preparing to dislodge the
knight with a5 uh so knight to c8 now
the the idea is if knight captures on d6
and you're threatening to pick up the b7
pawn the knight can capture right now
the b7 pawn is defended so instead we
have rook e to d1 uh and now a6 uh
forcing magnus to i remove or or capture
on d6 the magnus captures on d6 c
captures on d6 and now queen to e3 once
again centralizing the queen
asking black what do you want to do so
carlson will probably uh double up rooks
and the c file and try and take
advantage of the uh only open file on
the board that is the c file and there's
also the matter of uh somehow activating
this bishop
with all of these pawns on dark squares
the bishop will not have all that much
to do so here rajab kind of makes it
easy for magnus um he plays g5 and this
if anything allows magnus to
use this move in the future to maybe
free up his dark square bishop so here
he plays rook the c3 now ready to double
up on the c file and the queen to e8
here rajab just attacks the a4 pawn
and magnus doubles up on the c file he
ignores this pawn but rook the c7 right
away was also very very interesting
uh point is that if uh well if you don't
want to allow some like rook captures
here and you play rook to d7 we can
simply trade here and after queen
captures there's this d captures an e5
so you you will not be able to capture
bishop captures with check and your
entire position falls apart so uh after
this uh wonderful rook c7 move uh you're
not going to be able to play some like
rook to d7 you're gonna have to figure
out a way out of this position probably
queen captures on a4 and then we'll get
a similar position uh but it is possible
to to go for this rook lift right away
uh magnus first doubles up on the c file
and now uh rajabafa grabs the pawn on a4
knight the e7 is always better but
that's um only because we know that now
uh queen captures on a4 uh rajabov
grabbed the pawn and now rook to c7 now
magnus has a lot of pressure on the
position uh queen back to e8 bringing
the queen back to help out with the
defense and now h4 magnus of course
wants to
open up the position here or if uh rajab
captures an h4 which happened in the
game then queen to h6 now magnus is
threatening checkmate here uh but that
job doesn't mind just queen to g6 offers
a queen trade and defends on h7 so queen
captures an h4 by magnus and now knight
to a7 this is uh the absolute best way
to go you have to give up the pawn uh to
activate your uh your knight uh so rook
captures on b7 not knight to b5 putting
pressure on the d4 pawn so d captures on
e5 finally d captures an e5 still this
bishop will not
without all that much to do and king to
g2 now magnus has some ideas of shifting
this rook over to h1 to have a very nice
attack um against the h7 pawn so rook
did the e8 by tamor and now comes rook
to c6 the point is if you go rook to h1
now going after this pawn you can simply
block rook to f7 and it's it's not a
problem so magnus
lifts the other rook as well rook the c6
puts pressure on on this spawn also if
this rook was not here and it's a good
thing that it is then bishop captures an
e5 would be an idea uh the ace of the a6
pawn is hanging so what do you play here
here a tamer played knight to d4 puts
pressure on the rook here and the magnus
just captures on a6 but again doubling
up here uh definitely has its merits
because it's not easy to it's not easy
to defend this there's a triple attack
on the pawn here and if you try
something like h6 there's uh even the
idea of queen to h5 you could offer a
queen sacrifice and if it's accepted
then there's this very nice checkmate
here
so of course uh timur would not not um
capture the queen here he would have to
play some like rook to jade but then we
go into this rook to h7 check uh he
would have to give up the queen uh king
captures and then queen to f7 check
where the f6 pawn falls and after king
h8 queen captures with check and now
this pawn will fall
once the the king on pins and this pawn
is very weak so this should be winning
for white
but okay magnus grabs the a6 pawn first
why not create a beautiful past b pawn
uh and now knight the e6 by taymor now
now the knight can come to f4 so you
have to be very careful
rook to a7 now with a triple attack on
the h7 pawn and h5 tamer just advances
it
and now
it's already moved 34 so you should
really consider pushing that pass pawn
pawn to b4 always a great move but
magnus first decides to unpin he plays
king to f1 and now the bishop can
finally move
we rook to a8 tamer has to eliminate
some of the attackers for from the
seventh rank and magnus now of course
doesn't trade rooks he goes for the
queen rook to h7 check queen captures we
have rook captures and king captures and
it's a similar position to what we had
uh only now we grab the h5 pawn as well
this comes with check king to g7 and now
f4 so magnus has a queen for two rooks
uh and also he's up two pawns for the
moment so here at a job of captures we
have queen to g4 with check now you have
to defend the knight so king f7 and now
bishop captures an f4 and now uh timur
very gladly trades here because it's
much easier uh to just counter the queen
with two rooks then with a queen and an
additional piece it would be better for
magnus if it was a queen and knight but
queen and bishop can also be deadly so
knight captures queen captures and now
rook f the e8 and now magnus is up two
pawns but it's very hard to go through
those rooks however tamar is only down
to one minute on the clock here when
magnus played queen to f5 magnus had
some 10 minutes on the clock whereas
rajab had one minute on the clock so he
has to play very fast king to g7
uh once the rook moves you do not want
to allow something like pawn push and
then you know just losing this pawn and
you also have to have your rooks
protected you do not want to allow for
example this rook moves here we deliver
a check and then you know we either pick
up this rook or or we somehow connect
the to this rook uh that would be very
unfortunate so here we have f4 by magnus
again waiting with this b4 move uh and
rook to e7 now we have queen to g for
check king to f8 and now queen to h4 now
kind of putting pressure on the rook
here and preparing this e5 move and that
java makes it possible for magnets he
just repeats kink to g7 and now magnus
does push e5 and now how do you block
this well uh you could do something like
rook to a6 or you could do rook rook to
f8 rajabo chooses to bring the rook to
f8 closer to the black king
so it will be easier to defend them and
you will not have to worry all the time
about magnus delivering some check and
picking up the rook and now only now on
mu 48 does magnus push the pawn to b4
now is this a winning pawn push let's
see what happens
uh you could also consider instead of uh
playing before just you know improving
the position of your king but uh you
know it's been way too long now we have
to push the b pawn so king the g8 at a
job of waits to see what magnus does and
now comes a queen to g3 with check here
uh b5 right away uh definitely has its
merits and the the engine even agrees
that it's winning uh but uh you know uh
rajabov is very low on the clock and uh
magnus does not want to allow tamer to
use magnus magnus's time uh to calculate
his move so he plays queen to g3 check
rook to g7 and now queen to b3 with
check putting the queen behind the pass
pawn uh we have king to h8 and now even
e6 and now if f5 is played then that's
just over for the java so he plays f5
and now magnus pushes the pawn to b5 and
now we have a very critical moment uh
not a critical position critical moment
prior to the critical position where
rajab played rook to e7 puts pressure on
the pawn here and now the position is
completely winning for magnus but you
have to figure out how to achieve this
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for magnus while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is not
pawn to b6 uh unfortunately that's what
magnus played but that's not the winning
idea the the winning idea is queen to b4
and now it's uh very much different
because now you force black to make a
move and what can black play here well
obviously we could defend our rook like
this rook f2 e8 and now we push b6 but
now it's a it's a different story
because now after rook captures on e6 we
can simply play b7 and now after the
rook uh stops uh the pawn from queening
now it's queen to d for check king the
g8 and now queen to c for pinning this
rook uh the king has to defend king to
f7 only move and now queen to c7 check
picks up the rook on b8 that's how how
it's done or another way after for
example b6 is played you don't capture
on e6 you play rook to b7 uh stop the
pawn while it's still on b6 still
doesn't help now we have queen to b to
check king to g8 and now queen to g2
with check again picks up the rook on b7
and yes i know what you guys are
thinking these uh kind of end games are
that complicated so after rook the e7
queen to b4 absolutely winning it's
always something with the b4 square it's
it just is so i know most of you found
it because of that but magnus played b6
and now he allows a very crucial tempo
for a job if he plays king to g7 and
okay we have queen to d5 uh now if you
advance the pawn it's not a problem
we're just gonna play rook to b8
everything is nicely defended next move
we capture the pawn so magnus has to
figure out a different way he plays
queen to d5 still keeping an eye on
everything if the rook moves we can even
pick up the f5 pawn but king to g6 now
tamer plays it with absolute precision
b7 by magnus and now rook to b8 guarding
the queening square and there's no good
way for magnus to connect any checks so
queen to g2 check was played king f6 now
queen to g5 check king captures on e6
and now queen to g6 with check so we're
winning the f5 pawn king the d7 queen
captures with check and now king to d6
and now uh the problem is if you play
some like queen to f6 check we're just
gonna repeat king to d7 and now what do
you play there's really
uh not not much you can do so instead
magnus tried queen to d3 with check now
king to c7 queen to c for check hoping
that rajab captures the the b7 pawn but
if he does this queen before check now
wins the rook on e7 so rajabo just moves
back king to d7 now queen d5 check king
c7 queen c5 to king d7 and now queen to
d4 with check uh there's no good check
here that would pick up the rook so king
to c7 queen to c4 checking to d7 and now
f5 magnus has to try whatever is left
but this means giving up the b7 pawn so
rook captures on b7 and now f6
uh advancing the pawn rook to e5 played
incredibly quickly almost
instantaneously and
again it doesn't allow uh magnus to
connect anything if this check then king
here and the rook is nicely defending uh
defended we're attacking the pawn so
magnus tried queen to g4 check king to
d6 now queen the g6 check uh preparing
some uh g6 discoveries uh sorry f7
discoveries but now rook to b8 again
arachabov plays this instantly and he
doesn't care if you deliver this
checking e7 there is nothing to connect
here you don't you don't care about this
if king here going after the rook or
something like this
we don't care just rook five check we
pick up the pawn and that's it so
instead queen back to d3 check we have
king to e6 now comes queen to a6 with
check king f5 now queen to d3 with check
again hoping for uh king captures on f6
then we can play queen to d6 check and
win the rook on v8 then of course the
position is winning for white uh but
after queen to d3 check uh job just
repeated king e6 and now magnus uh knows
that there is nothing better so queen a6
king the f5 queen to d3 check and it was
in this position on move 74
that magnus and timur agreed to a draw
as there is nothing more to be done here
so a well played continuation of the
game uh stockfish versus alpha zero and
uh it was possible to to go for the win
here but uh
magnus wanted to even though he had 10
minutes on the clock he just didn't want
uh tamer to use his own time to
figure out moves so he played it
instantly and then he missed that
beautiful win with queen to b4 uh that
all of you found uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys uh enjoyed it
i would like to thank balcovich
enterprises ben mcgregor aaron anderson
garrett myers and mark adrian fosse for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this amazing event checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day